wissenschaftliche studien studie zeigt
shopping macht glücklich studie zeigt
warum männer auf verrückte frauen stehen
ist du dir menschen die im september
geburtstag haben sind intelligenter und
so viele produkte im netz deren
heilbringende wirkung natürlich auch mit
wissenschaftlichen studien belegt ist
nicht zu vergessen so sachen wie die in
fluege.de bei wissenschaftliche studien
die frage ich doch jetzt was kann ich
als laie als fachfremde tun um
wissenschaftliche studien besser zu
verstehen oder durch eine freundin der
sonne und setzt euch denn die antwort
wird euch nicht gefallen
[Musik]
also nochmal was können laien tun um
wissenschaftliche studien besser zu
verstehen
die antwort ist nichts also zumindest
nicht viel was auch wissenschaftliche
informationen findet man entweder in
fachbüchern so wie sie in uni bips
stehen vor allem die etablierten
wissenschaftlichen informationen oder in
wissenschaftlichen veröffentlichungen an
sagte pieper
da findet man vor allem auch die neuen
forschungsergebnisse aktuelle
wissenschaft und das ist ja das was uns
als gesellschaft oft am meisten
interessiert sei es jetzt der
klimawandel oder aktivkohle zahnpasta
wenn ihr aber mal so ein paper
reinschauen werde die oft feststellen
was aber nicht weil ihr dumm seit
sondern weil paper nun mal nicht für die
allgemeine öffentlichkeit geschrieben
sind paper sind dazu da dass sich
expertinnen und experten auf höchstem
fachlichen niveau und im detail
austauschen können also fachsprache ist
super für experten weil sie sich so sehr
detailliert und spezifisch ausdrücken
können fachsprache ist aber eine
fremdsprache für laien aber mai ist uns
eigentlich erhaschen nein du sprichst
doch ständig von studien also du
verstehst du aber wir sind zu blöd dafür
oder was
hier geht es ja nicht um intelligenz
oder sony geht es um ausbildung und um
zeit ich habe jetzt zum beispiel in der
chemie eine doktorarbeit gemacht
und so wie alle doktoranden musste ich
mir über jahre viel neues wissen
aneignen und ich wusste aktuelle
forschung verfolgen und dazu musste ich
ganz viele paper lesen auch aus
bereichen von denen ich davor keine
ahnung hat und das war am anfang sehr
anstrengend ich glaube das ist für alle
anstrengend aber mit der zeit schenkt
man die sachen dann doch irgendwann
schneller und holz ziel ist es nicht so
dass ich mir jetzt ihrem paper durchlese
und seen späte denke klar logisch aber
dafür bin ich vollzeit
wissenschaftsjournalistin und so habe
ich auch vollzeit nicht in
wissenschaftliche peter rein zu fixen
und ich besorge mir auch fachbücher und
ich spreche mit expertinnen und experten
bis ich alles verstanden habe und dieses
wissen kann ich denn hier an euch
weitergeben aber heißt das jetzt ihr
müsst mir blind vertrauen
jetzt so guter kommentat guten morgen
ich habe meinen eltern erzählt was du
für tolle videos machst danke alles was
sie sagen woher weißt du dass dir die
wahrheit sagt ich hab natürlich
gemeinden chemikerin wissenschaftliche
studien so weiter aber woher weiß ich
dass wie kann ich wissen dass du uns die
wahrheit sagst ja partie du mal 3
du kannst es schon du kannst es nicht
wissen ich verlinke hier an meine
wissenschaftlichen quellen in der video
beschreibung aber ihr habt
wahrscheinlich nicht die kapazitäten
diese quellen alle zu überprüfen es sei
denn sie sind jetzt zufällig aus dem
fachbereich oder ihr habt nichts anderes
zu tun im leben und übrigens selbst wenn
ihr meine sorgfalt und meine kompetenz
vertraut vielen dank
dann solltet ihr trotzdem nicht
ausschließen dass ich auch mal fehler
machen
seid also immer kritisch so hat eine
gesunde skepsis auch mir gegenüber
aber seid auch dankbar für
wissenschaftsjournalismus wir brauchen
guten wissenschaftsjournalismus denn nur
so bleibt forschung kein elitäres
experten geheimnis das hinter
fachsprache versteckt ist sondern wird
auch verständlich übersetzt aber
ich zum beispiel kann jetzt jede woche
ein video machen
das ist ja schon mal gut zum glück habe
ich noch viele tolle kolleginnen und
kollegen ich kann jetzt hier wenige von
vielen guten nennen zum beispiel unsere
funk homies von kurz gesagt oder auch
meine kollegen bei corps oder das
kollektiv der riß reporter die übrigens
auch dieses jahr den grimme online award
gewonnen haben aber alle alle
wissenschaftsjournalisten dieser welt
kommen nicht an gegen die massen von
scharlatan abzockern populisten die
wissenschaftliche studien missbrauchen
für ihre behauptungen die sie einfach
damit untermauern
weil sie genau wissen dass laien das gar
nicht so genau nachvollziehen können ja
jetzt ich hätte da einen vorschlag
stellt euch vor
zu jedem wissenschaftlichen paper gäbe
es eine allgemein verständliche
zusammenfassung der wichtigsten
ergebnisse einer erklärung der methoden
und eine einordnung inwieweit diese
ergebnisse praxis relevant sind
irgendwie wald die einfluss auf unser
alltägliches leben haben oder eben auch
noch nicht ständig vor wann immer jemand
irgendeine wille behauptung aufstellt
und dazu eine studie verlinkt könntet
ihr euch diese übersetzung dazu selbst
durchlesen und euch selbst aufklären
werde das nicht so geil geil ist jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen wie man es wäre
sauger der knackpunkt ist jetzt aber wer
schreibt diese texte eigentlich können
das nur die forscherinnen und
wissenschaftler selbst machen nur bis
man seine komplizierte arbeit in einen
verständlichen aber dennoch korrekt zum
text übersetzt hat er geht sehr viel
zeit und arbeit und kopfzerbrechen
gleichzeitig gibt es für wissenschaftler
keinen anreiz zeit und arbeit in eine
öffentliche kommunikation zu stecken
denn das wirklich belohnt
es gibt erste anreize inzwischen kann
man nicht nur forschungsgelder
beantragen sondern immer öfter auch
kommunikations gelder aber das reicht
nicht man sollte es nicht nur
ermöglichen man sollte ist nicht nur
melone
man sollte es verlangen erzwingen
ständig wollen der schule gebe es keine
mündliche noten würdet ihr euch dann
noch im unterricht beteiligen oder
hättet ihr es getan
eben klar nur weil man etwas machen muss
doch was noch nicht automatisch gut aber
man kann es lernen beispiel wissen
darin können relativ gut englisch denn
wir müssen's können denn die paper sind
auf englisch fachtagungen sind in der
regel international und auch im labor
sind meistens leute aus aller welt man
muss halt englisch können bevor jetzt
keine ahnung chemie studieren wollten
aber denkt scheiße ich kann kein
englisch in meinem semester hatten viele
eine eher schlechte noten in englisch
aber wenn man muss lehrplans einfach ich
kenne niemanden bei dem es am english
gescheitert ist und laien sprache ist
auch nur eine fremdsprache wie man
lernen könnt gut aber wie genau zwingt
man jetzt die leute dazu und das freunde
das ohne das ist genau die frage die wir
uns unbedingt stellen müssen und am
besten noch beantworten müssen nämlich
wie können wir verständliche
wissenschaft für alle zur pflicht machen
leute in einer zeit in der fakten und
meinungen immer öfter gleichgesetzt
werden müssen wir uns alle einig sein
dass wissenschaft und forschung
allgemeinverständlich sein muss und wir
zahlen die forschung ihr schließlich
forschung geht meistens aus
steuergeldern finanziert und da muss man
doch verlangen können dass forschung
nicht nur wissenschaftliche paper
produziert sondern auch eine öffentliche
version davon
ich habe jetzt noch keine konkreten
ideen wie man das jetzt sinnvoll in die
praxis umsetzt vielleicht fällt euch ja
was ein
aber ich dachte ich war jetzt mit diesem
video einfach mal den anfang und lenke
die öffentliche aufmerksamkeit auf
dieses wie ich finde sehr wichtiges
thema und wenn ihr helfen wollte bei der
aufmerksamkeit dann teilt dieses video
gerne unter dem hashtag wissenschaft für
alle und wir sehen uns in der endphase
mir bei social media folgt habt ihr hier
ist vielleicht schon mitbekommen dass
sich bei der bei der fernseh wissens
sendung quarks die nachfolge von ranga
yogeshwar antreten bresche nächstes jahr
werde ich also recht oft bei quarks zu
sehen sein aber keine sorge meint läuft
genauso weiter würde ich auch für nichts
auf dieser welt hier geben nur eine
sache möchte ich ausprobiert und sagen
würde ich gerne unsere upload tag von
donnerstag auf montag verlegt einfach
weil das besser mit quarks und so in
meinen neuen wochenplan passt man sich
mal gibt's hier und einen besseren start
in die woche
bis montag 36 das ist irgendwie sehr
strebe risch aber jogi passt es auch zu
uns findet nicht würde es jetzt gerne
mal testen das nächste woche kommt das
video nicht am donnerstag sondern an dem
montag danach wir sehen uns also erst in
anderthalb wochen
aber das warten lohnt sich denn saadet
war mal wieder am start mehr verrate ich
noch nicht dass dann bleibt sicher